[Musique]
bonjour je ne suis pas nathalie wolf je
ne suis pas patrice carmouze bonjour
mais ça peut s'arranger tout ça bonjour
et bienvenue dans envies de lecture
cette émission où même les livrer dans
laquelle on va essayer de vous les faire
aimer alors pour cette émission on a
deux personnalités qui vont nous
présenter des livres nous proposer des
livrables
oui nous allons d'abord recevoir
charlotte de 10o bonjour charlotte
bonjour charlotte denisot vous êtes
maître de conférences en qui vous avez
grandi dans les yvelines vous enseigner
dans les yvelines à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines en
droit public et également à l'université
d'assas et vous êtes questeur aux
affaires juridiques prêt auprès du maire
de garches qui n'ont pas le choix de
lire des bd décrivent et puis le sous
sol océanique blogging de la rivière
vous êtes vous êtes libraire à viroflay
votre librairie s'appelle une page de
vie et toutes les deux vous avez vous
nous conseillez des livres on commence
peut-être avec charlotte très bien
charlotte alors de quel livre allait
nous vous parlez alors aujourd'hui moi
je vais vous parler de deux ouvrages
dont je vous donne immédiatement le
titre il s'agit de la sortie déjà il ya
deux ans mais de maille absolue darling
de gabriel talent tu es de dark times de
thomas jane alors quand j'ai choisi ces
livres quand la tati wolf a demandé
d'intervenir c'est parce que je les
avais aimé élu au printemps 2000 vingt
ans durant le premier semestre à
quelques mois d'intervalle et
aujourd'hui quelques jours d'élections
américaines j'étais réalisé que ces deux
livres se faisait l'écho
parce qu'ils montrent chacun un visage
de l'amérique alors ce sont des livres
qui sont assez sont assez dures mais qui
sont aussi et le lumineux par par
certains aspects je vais commencer par
dark times qu'un publie un livre qui a
été publié chez rivages voir en 2018 et
qui est paru en poche la en 2020
je l'avais acheté chez mon libraire mois
à vaucresson à l'écriture parce que il y
avait une recommandation en manchette
c'est pour ça que j'avais choisie et
donc je n'ai pas du tout regretté c'est
un livre qui raconte à atlanta en 1940
pitt l'arrivée
des premiers policiers noirs dans la
police de la ville
c'est sous la pression de la communauté
noire qui malgré la ségrégation
participent aux élections municipales
que le maire se voit obligé de recruter
des policiers lors cliquez vite et dans
les deux personnages principaux qui sont
luxueuses box et son cas est typique et
coéquipier qui s'appelle tommie smith
le livre est très très bien documenté ce
qui est passionnant c'est qu'ils
racontent comment travaillent les
policiers noirs il montre le racisme de
la police blanches qui encore noyautée
par le ku klux klan alors on est
complètement dans la logique
ségrégationniste à savoir séparés mais
égaux et gommer ces paris donc il est
hors de question que les noirs ait dans
les quartiers blancs à idées hors de
question qu'ils coopèrent avec les
policiers blancs d'ailleurs le rapport
d' enquête souvent sont falsifiés ou
refusée ils partent à la poubelle et
évidemment ils ne peuvent pas non plus
partagé leurs locaux et on leur affecte
un local d'ailleurs indigne alors lui
livre commence or le meurtre d'une jeune
femme noire qui pour la dernière fois a
été vu par un policier blanc qui tentent
d'étouffer la faire boxer smith tente de
s'intéresser aux circonstances de sa
mort ils essayent d'enquêté mais les
blancs tentent de le dissuader
alors s'engage pour eux une enquête qui
est très difficile qui va les mettre
vraiment en grand danger et on voit dans
l'histoire l'intervention d'un policier
blanc les progressistes qui est un
vétéran de la guerre en europe qui
cherchent à les aider et qui va se
heurter à son coéquipier qui est le
stéréotype du vieux flic raciste et
corrompue
le livre est classique dans sa forme
c'est une enquête policière on va suivre
une intrigue policière qui est bien fait
il nous mène de bout en bout et pour moi
c'est pas là l'intérêt de l'ouvragé
ce qui est passionnant c'est vraiment ça
dit sa dimension historique et social
c'est le contexte dans lequel s'inscrit
l'histoire c'est à dire qu'on est dans
l'amérique raciste d'avant le grand
mouvement pour les droits civiques a
mené à part la martin luther king
et est ce qui est passionnant c'est tout
ce que nous dit tomasz müllen sur cette
époque sur ce vieux sur ces états qui
étaient d'anciens états esclavagistes
sur le lynchage convoi qui persistent
sur la ségrégation chez les policiers
qui peuvent d'ailleurs pas défiler en
uniforme parce qu'il risque d'être battu
et parfois battus à mort on voit bien
aussi l'extrême frustration au partage
de boxe et de ses collègues le poids des
négociations des injustices qu'ils
subissent et la position très ambiguë de
ces policiers noirs par rapport à la
population noire parce que la population
en noir voir en eux plutôt d'être être
les complices du pouvoir politique et
les opprime et c'est très bien montré on
voit comment la société américaine est
écartelé entre ses principes il le
fonctionnement réel de la société
voilà c'est toutes ces questions j'ai
trouvé passionnante qui résonne vraiment
avec les situations et il
afro-américains et et voilà ce que ça
rawbank je vous conseille parce qu'il ya
une bonne intrigue policière a surtout
cette analyse qui est très fine et mue
en scène à l amérique ségrégationniste
et est ce que on retrouve ça se passe en
48 ans au début du mouvement des droits
civiques mais est-ce que les traces de
tout ça on les retrouve à votre avis
encore aujourd'hui dans l'amérique
d'aujourd'hui pas s'empêcher d'y penser
il y avait un très grand reportage hier
sur tmc extrêmement intéressant mais
évidemment on peut pas lire non content
de ce qu'il a lu c'est juste après
l'assassinât de georges floride donc
assez skeena d'un noir par un policier
blanc
ce n'est pas nouveau parce que c'est une
longue liste b le set ce mouvement enfin
que cet assassinat a pris une ampleur
extraordinaire de fait sa médiatisation
qui s'était filmé quasiment en direct
moisson de l'agonie son week end russe
donc évidemment on peut pas s'empêcher
de lire et de penser aux extraordinaires
mouvement derrière que ça suscitait les
manifestations immenses aussi grande que
celle des années 60 le mouvement black
light matters et on peut pas le mettre
en non plus s'empêcher de médecins en
perspective avec les statistiques
d'aujourd'hui
ils disent qu un homme noir à trois fois
plus de chances qu'un blanc de son père
tué par la police
donc on voit bien que la situation est
loin les loin d'être résolue d'ailleurs
d'élections aujourd'hui de trump
montrent bien la méfiance des afro
américains envers le pouvoir politique
en place
l'abstention qui est massif chez les
noirs et puis même certains noirs qui
vont aller voter républicain je voyais
hier aussi que la police les noirs
craignent tellement la police blanche
ils préfèrent pour leur manifestation
prendre leurs propres milices pour
encadrer les manifestations pour ne pas
risquer d'avoir des policiers blancs et
des débordements
alors à vos de parler peut-être de votre
deuxième livre on va passer avec un
blondinet de la rivière
sur salat vous dis nous parler de livres
maria de julia kerninon qui est paru
chez l'iconoclaste oui parce que j'ai
trouvé que c'était un magnifique
portrait de deux femmes d'abord livre
maria est une
d'abord une petite fille jeune fille qui
grandit dans une île sa mère est
bretonne son père est norvégien elle a
une enfance heureuse elle grandit
entourée de l'amour des de ses parents
de sa famille oncles et tantes qui
vivent sur l'île également mais un
événement va l'obliger à quitter l'île
et elle s'installe à berlin à berlin
elle est jeune fille au pair et elle
rencontre son premier amour qui
malheureusement finit pas bien pour elle
puisque l'homme dont elle est amoureuse
la quitte et cette rupture également le
décès de ses proches qui va lui couper
aussi ses racines balle à faire partir
partir en voyage elle part loin en
amérique du sud elle se construit une
vie et elle rencontre à ce moment là un
deuxième à deuxième amour qui va se
s'installer dans la durée et
malheureusement un secret inavouable va
faire vaciller toutes les fondations
qu'elle a mis tant d'années à construire
mais ça c'est extraordinaire
en effet avec un secret qui se révélera
à la fin c'est très joli livre qui
paraît donc cherché de l'iconoclaste
exactement voilà merci beaucoup à l'euro
à charlotte tu veux évoquer un deuxième
livre my absolut darling
heureusement parce que vous reste plus
que quatre minutes en tout alla de
gabriel talent' week
alors c'est un livre qui est sorti relie
phénomène aux états unis ont sorti en
2010 est en france qui a déjà fait un
bon chemin en france alors c'est un
livre dont il est assez difficile de
parler céline extrêmement fins
extrêmement puissant c'est une véritable
oeuvre littéraire parfois l'idée c'est
vraiment de la littérature alors dans my
absolut en ligne pour mieux référencer
leur nature extraordinaire en est un
bandeau chino à 300 km au nord de san
francisco sur une côte sauvage elle très
tourmentée avec une végétation une
nature extraordinaire décrites de
manière somptueuse des ronces passiflore
d'étrangers cayeux découvre que les
hommes des fougères une nature aussi qui
se manifeste par les animaux qui sont
très présents les puces les tic les
araignées les boys noie fins et c'est là
ça donne tout un contexte et ensuite il
y a une histoire entre une fille et son
père
cette fille qui est sous l'emprise d'un
père d'un père qui violent d'un père
abusif mais d'affaires qui est très
ambivalente ski l'écologiste i les
survivalistes il avait mis les aussi
alcoolique et il passe sa vie à mettre
sa fille en garde contre le monde
extérieur ils la maltraite cette fille
mais il répète à l'envi qu'elle est son
amour absolu il peut la garder pour elle
essayée à la chanson entre l'art et
l'amour mais certaines pages sont
saumâtres est du rallye annonce qu'il
voit l' elysée les yeux fermés comme au
cinéma quand on ferme les yeux on
fermait dieu parce qu'on veut plus vous
imaginez la scène
c'est ce qui se passait en même temps il
ya une telle attraction ça donne pas
envie de le lire quand on dit ça ça me
paraît trop repoussant mais c'est
vraiment une expérience extraordinaire
oui c'est un très grand livre est quand
même même en effet ici comme comme le
dit nathalie à des passages extrêmement
dur à blandine de la rivière il y avait
aussi des vermines dont voulait parler
de gwenaëlle robert qui est chez robert
laffont
alors oui tout à fait là c'est plutôt un
roman historique
on est en 1800 le 25 décembre 1800 et
napoléon est victime d'un attentat rue
saint-nicaise
il s'en sort malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de victimes collatérales et
napoléon est persuadé que l'instigateur
de cette attente des instigateurs de cet
attentat sont les jacobins donkey
battement d acheter dans des portes et
une bonne centaine ce que foucher va
faire or le les véritables instigateurs
de cet attentat sont trois royalistes
dont joseph de l'immoler ans que
l'auteur a dont l'auteur a retracé toute
la vie est allé chercher ce qu'il est
devenu
ce que lol intrigue aussi essentiel
c'est qu'il a réussi à échapper à la
police de fouché même s'il était brisée
par les remords duo dû au nombre de
victimes qu'à causer cet attentat et à
travers ce roman l'auteur mais la mêle à
la fois les personnages célèbres
napoléon joséphine foucher l'immoler ans
et des petits inconnu qui permettent de
rendre vivant cette page d'histoire
c'est bizarre ce qui très facilement
c'est bizarre comme titre pour un roman
historique nevermind
non oui c'est un roman historique
français et sur la france il est
effectivement le titre est en anglais et
le l'explication se trouve dans les 10
dernières pages voilà donc je vous
laisse les découvrir d'accueil alors
donc c'est robert laffont et puis parce
que aussi il ya des ados et puis on a
tous aimé euros vous les nounous
conseiller de bons films bd qui
s'appelle d'autres vegas et de pierre
alary exactement c'est une bande
dessinée donc on est en californie en
1848 la californie a s'est séparé des
fans le mexique l'a perdue la californie
la californie n'est pas n'appartient pas
encore aux états unis c'est une zone
politique un peu entre les deux et il ya
un général le général gomez qui raf
toutes les terres pour pouvoir les
revendre beaucoup plus cher et on avait
la famille vega qui a perdu ses terres
et le fils l'héritier et en est à madrid
et reçoit une lettre lui annonçant le
décès de ses parents et lui demandant de
revenir au pays
beatty il revient donc ils découvrent
une région désolée
les paysans se révèle comme ils peuvent
et utilise le mythe populaire daily
ces ions d'avoir un bandeau sur les yeux
et il faut très vite réprimés par le
général gomez qui était assez dur et
sanguinaire et donne vega décide lui de
le reprendre à son compte avec tout ce
qu' il est adroit il manie l'épée il est
à cheval il a de l'argent et c'est plus
facile pour lui et donc c'est le zorro
de notre enfance des illustrations 5
smic et on voit là avec une petite
surprise en bas c'est très très bien
d'avoir conseillé une bd merci merci
infiniment dont bing de la rivière merci
infiniment charlottetown denisot donc on
rappelle peut-être les titres de
charlotte de quelques conseillers
charlotte denisot alors dalton de thomas
smullen éditions rivages émail absolut
darling de gabriel talent' galles ce
master est à l'origine de la rivière
donc de les librairies une page de vie à
viroflay cediv maria de julia kerninon
et nevermind de wemmel robert et donne
vega de pierre alary merci infiniment à
toutes les deux merci beaucoup d'attali
merci patrice
on
[Musique]